(light music)
- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan here.
I've always been drawn to creative things.
I like to see, change
new things in the world,
and because of that,
I've been drawn to careers
where I can most apply my creativity,
especially in an abstract sense.
And algebra is perhaps the
purest expression of creativity,
and that's why I've worked in everything
from computer programming,
to product design,
to a hedge fund analyst,
where you're investing in stocks.
And in all of them,
it was incredibly creative
and used a lot of algebra.
But don't take my word for it.
You're going to meet some of my friends
who can tell you a lot
more about the connection
between algebra and work and creativity.
(typewriter typing)
(light music continues)
- I think my idea of how creativity works
in STEM jobs has changed
since I've gotten to college.
I used to think that
all the mathematicians
would be just locked away in some office
and typing on their computers
or writing down equations
by themselves and coming up
with incredibly beautiful ideas
just by themselves.
But I'm realizing now that I'm in college
that mathematics and creativity,
it's a lot about communication
and it's a lot about trying to build off
of each other's ideas and
bounce ideas off of each other
and build upon ideas that
have already been made
by people decades ago.
And I think that the facts
that we all come with it,
with our own perspectives
and different ideas
and different ways of being creative,
allows math to advance further.
Because we can all
combine our creative ideas
into something bigger.
- We collect data on everything.
The ability to use that
data in a smart, safe,
and efficient way depends
on new applications
of mathematical concepts
to these new and innovative data sets.
As we get to that point,
we'll start to be thinking
outside the box a lot more
and we'll be a much more
innovative digital society.
But that can't happen unless
we start trying to be creative
and not just rely on tried and true.
(typewriter typing)
(light music continues)
- Creativity's really important for me
as a future job, as a
part of my future job.
I would want to do something that changes
and then I can use
problem-solving skills constantly.
I feel like when I make animations
or when I figure out how
to explain something,
I am really, I love that,
because it's, there's so
many different solutions,
but knowing that you can
try to find and experiment
with different ones and maybe
create something beautiful
is really, I don't know, inspiring to me.
- Mathematigals is an
educational initiative
that I co-founded
with a fellow mathematician,
Jess Williams,
and what we're trying
to do is make maths fun
and accessible and encourage more girls
to pursue careers in maths.
Creativity is essential here
because we're trying to think of ways
that people will enjoy maths
and it will be fun and accessible to them.
Different creative techniques
that we've been using
are trying to present
mathematical problems
in fun, short videos
and that explain the problem in a way
that everybody will understand
and will make them want to learn more
and discover more about the
topics that we're talking about.
- I'm really lucky that I
get to be creative every day
in my work and I have been
since I got into this field
of data science.
In general, across the last
decade, my work has really been
about designing and
testing innovative ways
to capture human behavior
within game-based assessments.
My collaborators and I,
from the time I was in
graduate school to now,
use a variety of different
modeling techniques
from various fields.
We'll pull things from engineering,
aerospace, more basic mathematical models,
to help us achieve this goal.
We get to think outside the box.
We get to think about how we
can pull in different types
of thinking from different fields
to help us better
understand human behavior,
human cognition, learning.
It's really exciting and really novel,
and it's something that,
because of the field that I'm in,
I've been able to do this
now for multiple years.
(typewriter typing)
(light music continues)
- Whenever I wanna have,
come up with a solution to a
problem and I don't have it,
my immediate reaction is to
go outside and go on a walk.
I love walking in all kinds of weather.
It's kind of, it's just,
I feel like with the peace and calm,
moving away from the problem
and stepping away from it,
sometimes I get way better
ideas and it inspires me.
But I also think there's
something to be said
about not being inspired.
Not always is amazing. (laughing)
I feel like sometimes I
get struck with inspiration
for how I want to explain
a Khan Academy video
or how I wanna approach a piece of art
or how I want to approach a math problem.
But sometimes, it doesn't come.
So I feel like what the best solution is
when you are trying to get
into that creative zone
and you can't is to just do it
and try to do something anyway.
Write something or write your equations.
Try to figure it out.
And if you make mistakes, that's okay.
Because it's something to jump off of,
and maybe, sometimes seeing
what you already know
down on paper can help you
come up with better ideas
and could help you be more creative.
- Forcing yourself to
just conjure a solution
simply does not work.
Instead, take a break from a task.
Pick something else up,
like a physical sport
or even video games.
And then come back to
the original problem.
That can do wonders.
(typewriter typing)
(light music continues)
- One of my biggest passions
is documentary filmmaking.
I've been making videos
since I was in middle school.
And I remember being, it
was always a challenge,
because sometimes I wanted to do things,
but I didn't have the equipment to do it.
I really wanted to record
myself in a certain way,
but there was no way for
anyone to hold the microphone,
or I didn't have a dolly or
any expensive camera equipment.
So, I remember,
I think the most important thing to do
is just use what you have.
I would tape a cross-country
ski pole to my ceiling
and hold the microphone that way.
Or I would put a pillow in a box
and then speak into the
microphone with that
as my makeshift sound studio
or make a tripod out of a pile of books.
And I feel like it's
kinda the same with math.
You are, sometimes, you
don't know how to solve
a really big problem,
and you only have all the
tools you've been taught
up to that point.
And maybe there is a
fancier way of getting
to the solution, but a lotta the time,
it's just about combining
things that you already have
in your, that you've already learned,
and coming up with a solution that way.
And sometimes, that comes
up with some really creative
and unexpected solutions to problems.
(typewriter typing)
(light music continues)
- Algebra is really the unifying thread
of almost all of mathematics.
You may think algebra is boring,
but it is the one tool you can use
to not only understand
but unlock the universe.
Creative algebra is used
in computer game design.
It powers how artificial
intelligence works.
Mastering algebra will provide you
with the ability to decode and understand
many complex systems.
In my opinion, if you can master algebra,
you can master anything.
(light music continues)